we have some good news to share tonight
emma berkey the 18 year old young woman
from las vegas who suffered rare blood
clots after getting the
johnson and johnson vaccine is making
some progress with her recovery
orkomana he's in our newsroom with how
she's doing right now orco well brian
family and friends say emma berkey is
now able
to move her head and her facial features
a little bit more which is great news
this comes more than a month after they
say she suffered a severe reaction
from the johnson and johnson kova 19
vaccine loved ones say her symptoms
included blood clots in her brain and
seizures which all started about 10 days
after getting the shot on march 20th
but she's making some major strides with
her recovery at a hospital in california
emma's family and friends say her latest
mri shows
no abnormalities she can now move her
head in all directions
and her eye movement is also continuing
to improve
the berkey family's pastor who's
speaking on their behalf
says this is nothing short of a miracle
we know that the road ahead
is long and is intense yet
it's better together and so yeah we
thank god for it we
continue to pray for more miracles to
come and we believe there's more to come
ratner tells me the next steps for emma
involve a continuation of her acute
physical therapy
emma is one of six women across the
country who have reportedly experienced
severe blood clots after getting the j j
vaccine
out of around 7 million shots given that
makes this
a one in a million occurrence now loved
ones have set up a gofundme page
to help with the hospital bills we have
a link to this on our website
8newsnow.com reporting live in the
newsroom tonight orco mana 8 news now